what about that guy over there eatin
sunblock that's the most offensive one
yeah you know you gotta get it from the
inside it's actually not about putting
it on your skin you got to get in the
bloodstream yeah I definitely think
albinism is pun fairly representative in
most media we don't see that much of us
on screen or if I do I feel like we're
always seen as like the villain or we
look kind of crazy like they'll put a
lot of makeup on us
our characters revolve around our
condition and it's like that really
shouldn't be the case at all the first
time I saw and I'll buy an opener on
film or TV was was the Benchwarmers
oh he's supposed to be the vinyl he
doesn't look like he has albinism yeah
like that all the Benchwarmers is one of
my favorite movies and like how he like
they have him like living in like a
closet because he's scared of the Sun
like he's legitimately terrified of the
Sun oh my god yes we do burn when we get
in the Sun but it's after like a circus
yeah extensive time yeah it's not that
dramatic no you pretend to be my friend
the way you pretend everything this is
Jeremy from powder I haven't seen this
in a super long time yeah except for
powder there's literally no like movie
or TV show that has albino characters as
like good guys a lot of people when they
when they ask me about albinism they say
oh like powder and I'm like no and a lot
of novels and films like people with
albinism are supposed to be magical and
you know there's even like cultures
where they believe people are albinism
they're like body parts are magical
people in like Tanzania or like
different parts of Africa getting like
their limbs cut off so people can like
give it to witchcraft actors to create
like potion sort of is happening to this
day into
in parts of Africa you know this is like
the the main representation that they've
seen you know if they've never seen a
person with albinism in real life and I
feel like it's very irresponsible you
know the only have this you know is what
people know about albinism Silas from
The Da Vinci Code no he looks like a
little Dom B yeah he just looks evil
honestly I hope I don't look like that
his hair is bleached white he could kind
of pull it off I guess but I prefer if
it was someone who actually had albinism
yeah why are we painting people [ __ ]
yeah I'm not gonna lie it did kind of
look like a person with albinism yeah
definitely way better than Benchwarmers
it bothers me when I see people who
don't have albinism playing characters
with albinism because I have a lot of
friends who are performers with albinism
they're actors they're looking for work
and they're not being offered these
roles I feel like is that you know
that's the character and you're doing
everything correctly it's spreading a
good message I have no problem with it
if you're trying to get a person with
albinism gonna personally don't even
think of that trying to escape I know
from the princess right oh my gosh but
yeah just why not the albino like oh
yeah that's just so straightforward like
give him another name he doesn't look
like he has autism at all he looks like
you should like I don't know drink some
water
Prince of the count always insist on
everyone being healthy before they're
broken like he doesn't even look like
hygienic yeah definitely weird and of
course he's in a dungeon yeah
yeah well he's all twisted mine like
anything we're supposed to be in the
shadow hey just like looking on the rest
of the world I always felt like people
think that I guess we're the ones that
aren't supposed to have any friends like
even people in my life I think are
surprised that I'm as talkative as I am
looks like this guy's deployed too much
World of Warcraft
[Music]
we are getting aggravated the twins from
the Matrix Reloaded
I guess when they came out there was
like a really big controversy you know
from the albinism community the
filmmakers came out and said they're not
actually albinos they're supposed to be
ghosts
the cover name is I just felt like they
use those to just cover themselves up
because they could have made it like
they could have done a good hair but if
other good luck yeah they wanted to
glasses soup kind of cool if they were
gonna do this like if they're supposed
to be people albinism I feel like yeah
they should you talk about people with
albinism that was fine I like done
nothing what I never killed anyone
before what [ __ ] you read admitted skits
always wanted for murder and you're
laying in bed next to me Gavin like a 16
year old girl on the telephone whitey
from from me myself and Irene okay why
do you like come on that's the most
offensive one I really like this movie
because actor actually has albinism
realized this was like you know
something he he wanted to do is act it
does make a difference to see people
with albinism really playing people
albinism because you really get a sense
of who they are and like their real
features and not just food like people
in Hollywood they are thank you do we
live sunshine in his life
carefully appeal
yeah that's nice enough I liked how this
character was represented in the film I
didn't really have a problem with this
one personally I think it's easier to
laugh at yourself when you know it's
it's not someone else playing that part
that doesn't experience it when I was
younger I had never seen anyone else
with albinism I felt very alone and felt
like this is how the world views me you
know seeing what the media portrayed
albinism as it kind of it kind of like
formed my idea of how people see me
everyone feels like I'm evil or bad or
you know that I look weird you know this
is the only representation that I'm
seeing and that they're seeing and when
I walk out the door they're coming up to
me and saying weird things to me let's
say the New Avengers movie that comes
out next year there's an albino
character in it and where it's supposed
to be like the new evil villain imagine
being up like a regular albino and then
going out the next day after this
billion dollar movie just came out
United mean kids besties they're gonna
look at us like there goes him you know
to me like if I was thinking oh it's you
not I mean it's like I feel like if we
were actually seeing more and more
normal it wouldn't be such like oh my
gosh here's there's him it would just be
like oh wow you're not I mean just
regular we want to probably see more
people like us and different roles then
better music you know I don't mind that
there's like evil yeah when you
characters i photo should be a balance
where there's more positive characters
as well should actually have a person
without yes they're gonna portray that
at least I mean how hard could be no one
in society today is gonna like look up a
condition and like research its exactly
yeah I'll see it see it has to be in
like the new purge or like black panther
or you know something like that and then
they'll actually be like it's you know
normal
[Music]
[Music]